let's say that some particle is moving
up or down so it's moving in one direct
dimension the vertical dimension and we
know its position as a function of time
its position is given as a function of
time as t to the third power
minus 6 t squared plus nine t and we're
going to assume that our time is
greater than or equal to zero so you
could imagine you could imagine a dot
a dot here
moving along this vertical line
moving along this vertical line maybe it
moves up it slows down maybe it stops
maybe it switches direction maybe it
comes back down maybe it slows down it
comes back and maybe moves up back up
again who knows what it does we really
haven't analyzed this thing right over
here yet but what we do want to analyze
over the course of this video is when is
the particle speeding up
so when is it
speeding
speeding up when is it speeding up and
before we think about that let's just
think about what it means to speed up
well let's think about the situation
where the particle is moving upwards
and let's just say upwards the upwards
direction is positive so when it's
moving upwards its velocity as a
function of time
is greater or at any given at that
moment our velocity is going to be
greater than zero
and so if our velocity if we're moving
up what does it mean to be speeding up
well that means our velocity should be
increasing in the upward direction or
that the acceleration should be positive
as well
so the acceler to be speeding up our
acceleration
at that time should also be greater than
zero
if our acceleration was zero then we
would be moving at a constant velocity
if our acceleration were negative right
over here that means we would be slowing
down we would be decelerating in that
we'd be decelerating in that direction
now let's think about well what else we
could be speeding up
well if our velocity at some moment in
time is negative
so if our velocity at some moment in
time is negative and our acceleration is
also negative and our acceleration is
also negative then we will be speeding
up in the downward direction our
velocity is already negative we're
already going downwards but then we'll
be going downwards faster and faster and
faster our velocity will become more and
more and more negative because the
acceleration is less than zero so these
are both the cases when we would be
speeding up and so now that we've
clarified that i encourage you to pause
this video and try to answer this
question over what intervals of time if
any will this particle be speeding up
well to answer that let's just try to
figure out the velocity as a function of
time and acceleration as a function of
time
and we know that velocity
we know that velocity is just the
derivative of the position function with
respect to time
so let's write that down so i'll do it
right over here
our velocity as a function of time the
derivative is the derivative of 3 of t
to the third power is 3t squared
minus 12t
plus 9
and our acceleration function is going
to be the derivative of the velocity
function with respect to time
so our acceleration function
is going to be let's see 6 t
minus
12.
now we just need to think about over
what intervals are these things positive
or negative so let's think about the
velocity function first when is this
going to be positive so let's just think
about when is 3t squared minus 12t
plus 9 when is that greater than 0.
well let's see we could just we could
try to factor this left-hand side what i
like to do is get rid of this this
leading coefficient this 3. so let's
divide both sides by 3 and we get t to
the third power minus four t plus three
is greater than zero this is pretty
straightforward to factor this is t
minus three times t minus one is greater
than zero
and if i have the product of two things
when is the product of two things going
to be greater than zero well when they
have the same sign they're either both
positive or they're both negative so
this is going to happen when either
t minus three
greater than zero and
and
t minus one greater than zero so that's
the case where they are both positive
or
t
minus three is less than 0
and
t
minus 1 is less than 0. so this is the
case where they are both negative either
they're both going to be positive or
they're both going to be negative in
either of those cases negative times
negative is positive positive times
positive is a positive so let's work
through this so if you add 3 to both
sides here you get t is greater than 3
and
t
add 1 to both sides is greater than 1.
so that's one case
or
add three to both sides here t is less
than three
and
and add one to both sides here t is less
than one now we could simplify these
further if t is greater than three and t
is greater than one well if it's greater
than three you know you're going to be
greater than one so really this
this t is greater than one isn't really
adding anything so we could just
simplify this to t is going to be
greater than 3
or
or
and then over here
t is less than 3 and t is less than 1.
well if you're less than 1 you're
definitely less than 3. so this we can
write rewrite this part of the
expression as t
is less than one
so this right over here this is the case
where our velocity is positive so this
is the case where our velocity is
positive we just let's just remember
that so this
if t is greater than three or t is less
than one
then v of t
v of t is greater than
is greater than zero
now if we did it the other way around if
we had this as less than zero this less
than less than less than would carry all
the way in and then you would have when
you had then this clause would be
actually let me just work it through
just so that we don't get confused but
it's actually essentially just going to
be the inside of this interval but let's
just let's just calculate it just for
fun so when is our velocity going to be
negative so 3t squared minus 12t
plus 9
is less than zero divide both sides by 3
t squared minus t plus
three is less than zero factor it t
minus three times t minus one is less
than zero well you're going to have
something less than zero when they have
opposite sides so either
t
minus three is greater than zero and
t minus one is less than zero so
different signs or
or
t minus three
is less than 0
it's negative and
not add and
and
t minus 1 is greater than 0 so they have
to be different signs so add 3 to both
sides here you get t is greater than 3
and
and
t is less than 1. well that's impossible
something can't be greater than 3 and
less than 1. so this whole clause is
actually there's no t for which that is
true
luckily this is an or so if we can just
make this true that's enough
so add 3 to both sides t is less than 3
and
t is greater than 1. or we could say
that one is less than t is less than
three this tells us this is when our
velocity is less than zero so we know
the intervals where our velocity is
positive we know the intervals where the
velocity is negative now let's think
about the intervals where the
acceleration is positive or negative and
this is a little bit simpler
algebraically so when is this positive
so 6t minus 12 when is that greater than
zero well that's when 6t is greater than
12 or when t is greater than 2 when t is
greater than 2 our acceleration as a
function of time
is greater than 0 and similarly if you
made this less than 0 this would be less
than this would be less than and so when
t is less than 2 our acceleration as a
function of time
is
less our acceleration at those times i
should say is less than zero
so when is both velocity greater than
zero and acceleration greater than zero
so when are we speeding up in the
upwards direction
so let me copy and let me paste this so
let's think about this case right over
here and actually let me since i'm in
copy and paste mode let me copy and
paste this that's going to be when we're
speeding up in the downward direction
we're getting faster and faster in the
downward direction
so copy and paste put that right over
here
so let's see we want our velocity be
greater than zero
our velocity is greater than zero when t
is greater than three so t has to be
greater than three
or t is less than one
or t is less than one that's that
constraint and when is our acceleration
greater than zero our acceleration is
greater than zero when t is greater than
two so i could say and
and
and
t is greater than
greater than two
so how will both of these be true this
is an and here both of these have to be
true
well if t is greater that if t is 2.5
then only my acceleration is positive
not my velocity and if my velocity if
time is
0.5 my velocity is positive but my
acceleration isn't
so the only way to make both of these
true is if t is greater than 3 t is
greater than 3 then the first clause is
true t is greater than 3 then the second
clause is true so this is going to be
true when t
is greater than three that means we're
accelerating that means we're we're
going faster in the upwards direction
faster
upwards
i could say
and now let's think about when we are
getting faster in the downward direction
when is our velocity less than zero well
our velocity
is less than zero when
one is less than t is less than three
and when is our acceleration less than
zero
when so this this has to be true and
our acceleration has to be zero and t
has to be less than two
so what what ts satisfy both of these
well if t is between one and two
so we get one is less than t is less
than two then we're moving faster
faster
downwards
so if we want to think about it in
intervals we could say that we are
speeding up we can we're speeding up
over the interval not including 3 but
from 3 to infinity
and that's why i didn't put brackets i
put parentheses this doesn't include the
end points so that's when we're we're
going faster upwards and we're going
faster downwards in the interval between
1
and 2.